[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES BYERS: Good morning.
Welcome to Google
Cloud Next 2018.
I hope you all had a chance
to enjoy the keynote just
prior to this and are
excited to get started
for a week of
learning about cloud
and what Google is
doing in this market.
Today, we're here to talk about
managing your costs in GCP.
This is IO 118, and we're
looking at managing your costs
and how to best structure
your GCP resources
to make cost reporting simple.
So we're here to answer
one key question.
That question is,
what is the best
way to structure your
resources in order
to understand and manage costs?
Now, we're going to go through
this in seven sections--
a brief introduction, a
look at the fundamentals
and foundations of
billing on Cloud.
We'll talk about organizations--
specifically, GCP organizations.
We'll talk about folders,
labels, a few advanced topics.
And then we will attempt
to leave a lot of time
for your questions.
There are two mics.
You're welcome to come
up, ask the questions
you have about billing.
And if we run out
of time, there are
lots of billing product
managers and engineers here
who are happy to help
today or at another time.
So a quick introduction.
Who am I?
I'm James.
I'm a product manager in Google
Cloud and I work on billing.
And billing is a challenge
in an environment like Cloud.
A lot of services
bill by the second.
A lot of services bill
at extremely high rates.
We have dozens and dozens
and dozens of services
reporting back onto your bill.
And our mission is to
make billing trustworthy,
transparent, simple,
and predictable.
And we're working with
a great engineering team
to do that every day.
And we're always
trying to provide you
capabilities and
features and new services
at customer friendly prices.
And billing has a big
part to play in that.
So today, you'll look at how
to use projects, organizations,
folders as your primary ways
of structuring GCP resources.
We'll also look at
labels, which are a way
to cross cut across
those boundaries
to do more advanced reporting.
And we'll introduce billing
exports and billing reports
to dive into that billing data.
Now there are a
few other sessions
later in the week at Next,
and I'll call those out,
as they're great
ways to go deeper
into how to handle billing,
reporting, and other billing
needs.
And so the way we'll
structure today
is we'll take a
journey together.
We will start as
a solo developer.
I'm told that all
solo developers have
a dog and work in a garage.
We'll start there
and move all the way
across to being a large,
multinational corporation
with thousands of
developers working
across dozens of projects
and services in Cloud.
Now first, let's ask where
you are in your journey,
just to get a quick
show of hands.
How many solo
developers do we have?
There's one-- at least one.
I don't see any
dogs in the room.
That may be a policy.
Apologies.
Next time, we'll try and
let you bring your dog.
How many CIOs or CTOs of
multinational companies?
Anyone?
Got at least one, two.
I'm kidding a little bit.
We know that most
of our audience
sit in between
those two extremes.
So now, a real show of hands.
How many of you used GCP today?
Amazing.
Pretty much everyone
in the room.
How many of you have
an organization-- a GCP
organization?
Most of the people in the room.
How many of you use folders?
Ah, now we're down to
maybe 20% of the room.
How many of you use labels?
Ah, I saw a lot of those folder
hands stay up for labels.
That's good.
Finally, the bonus question.
How many of you export
your billing data
using the BigQuery export?
Good turnout.
Thank you very much.
That is going to be a theme
throughout today's journey.
I'm going to try and
convince everyone here
to export your data to the
BigQuery billing export
because it's amazing.
So we're at different
stages in our journey,
and we're going to start small,
go all the way across to big.
And hopefully, along
the way, you'll
see yourselves in the
structures we're looking at
and see tips you can take
home, take to your teams,
and use in your
journey on Cloud.
Along the way, you will
see eight green slides
like this one.
They are tips and tricks
and best practices
and takeaways that
you should think
about for any use of Cloud.
And we'll recap them at the end.
And of course, these slides--
this presentation will
be publicly available,
so no need to take
furious notes.
You can always come
back later and see
what we've talked about today.
So the fundamentals
of billing on Cloud.
Let's start with projects.
Projects are the core
organizing entity in Cloud.
When you have a service such as
Compute Engine, or Kubernetes,
or Cloud SQL, or Storage, you'll
see them creating resources
in the context of projects.
Now, projects are
containers for resources,
and also describe the
settings and permissions
and other metadata
around your workloads.
A separate concept in Cloud is
that of the billing account.
And a billing account
defines who pays
for projects and resources.
Now, a project is always
paid for by a single billing
account.
And billing accounts actually
have their own separate roles
and permissions from
projects in the hierarchy.
A billing account
operates in one currency.
And it can be funded by a
credit card, a debit card,
other payment instruments,
depending on jurisdiction,
or it can be funded
by an invoice.
Billing accounts are always
funded on a monthly basis.
Now, it's easy-- in fact,
it's incredibly easy
to move projects between
billing accounts.
You can do it
yourself, and you can
self-serve that process using
the billing section of Cloud.
One request-- if we could
reload the presentation.
I've noticed we're
on an older version,
so if you could just
hit reload in the middle
on the same screen, I'm sure
it'll come up with the latest.
So in addition to projects,
we have both organizations
and folders, which are ways
of containing and grouping
projects.
The best way to think
of these structures
is that they mirror
your organization.
That's why we named
organizations Organizations.
And folders can
be nested, and you
can think of them as the
primary key, in a sense,
to your projects.
Now, a project can only live
and be owned by one folder.
Organizations can also
contain billing accounts,
allowing for the central
management of billing roles
and permissions, but they're
independent from projects.
They have separate roles,
separate permissions.
Finally, at the most granular
level, we have labels.
Labels are ad hoc, key value
pairs assigned to resources.
It is.
We just have to
hit reload on it.
We'll be all set.
All right.
Thanks.
We'll pick it back
up with labels.
Labels associate resources
across projects and
are the crosscutting ways of
doing reporting that you can't
model with nested folders.
So a number of examples here.
What team is working on
a particular resource?
Is it a database?
Is it in production?
Is it in Mountain View?
Is it active?
Is it pending?
You can apply those key
value pairs across resources.
And additionally, they may have
other powers on a per service
basis.
But for billing, they're a
tremendously powerful way
to crosscut reporting.
And critically, they appear in
your BigQuery billing export--
a topic you will hear
me keep hammering on
until I've convinced
every single one of you
that it's a wonderful
thing to do.
Now, cost management is
how we report and allow you
to control those costs across
all of your projects, folders,
and within your organization.
Now, I'm going to draw
a distinction here
between your invoice,
which tells you how much,
and cost management, which
tells you why and where costs
were raised.
And we'll look in a moment
at how those differ.
Cost management lets
you slice and dice
cost, particularly by
project, but also by label,
and over time, folder.
And the major areas are
cost reporting, budgets
and alerting, to
let you know when
you've hit certain thresholds
of cost, and our famed export.
There are four other sessions
with a lot more detail that you
may like to attend later on--
monitoring and forecasting,
saving money on Compute
Engine-- a topic worthy
of its own discussion--
a deep dive into exporting
data, and cutting and slicing it
with Data Studio, and a
financial governance session
about controlling cost.
Now first big, green tip.
Of course, you already
knew what it would be,
and we'll come back
to it later on.
It's turn on the
BigQuery billing export.
Now, this export exports
extremely fine grain data
about your usage of Cloud.
But even at high volume, it's
unlikely to cost you very much
to turn on this export.
Your free cap includes some
storage that will likely
cover your use of this export.
But we let you
turn it on, so you
have control of both access to
it and what project it sits in.
And you can turn it on in the
billing section under Billing
Export, choose a project
that it resides in,
and choose a data
set to host it in.
So that's tip number one.
So let's get started with
our Hello, World example.
We have one billing account,
one project, and five services
that we're funding.
So a billing account
pays for a project.
Project owns resources.
And let's flip our colors so we
have a little color coded key
for the rest of this
discussion, and note
that the pays for is the
dotted green line, and owns
is the blue line.
Billing accounts don't own
projects, they just fund them
and that's an
important distinction
as we go through our
discussion of ownership.
So we've just started
our new company--
one billing account,
one production project.
Things are great.
Users are pouring in.
We've got all our resources
under the hood there.
I've hidden them so that
it's a little bit easier
to read these slides, but
under that project are
all of the resources in GCP.
Things are going great.
We've hired two developers--
Alice and Bob.
Alice and Bob are
off to the races.
They're staying up late.
They're working hard to get
us that next set of users.
Unfortunately, Bob is not the
world's greatest Linux hacker.
He doesn't realize that rm -rf
works quickly and efficiently
to destroy your files.
Alice is a really fast typist.
But every now and then,
she forgets a where
clause in her SQL statements.
Now, I'll do my
own show of hands.
In my time before Google, I
have done both of these things
on large production systems.
I ran an uncapped where clause
on a 100 million row table.
Caught that a couple
million rows in.
I have deleted the root file
system of a production Linux
host.
It's always the
pause that gets you.
You sit and you think, why
is this taking so long?
Oh.
Another tip along the way--
you can change the radius
of the smile in the faces
on Google Slides.
So I highly recommend you
explore those advanced
features.
[LAUGHTER]
So from Hello, World to hello,
development environment.
Why on Earth would we run
everything in one project,
give everyone permission to it?
Of course, it's best
practice to carve
out environments, to isolate
environments by stage
and by who's using them.
So we forgive Alice and Bob.
We have a blameless post-mortem.
We should have offered
better protections.
They're still happy.
They're still working away,
not running terrible removes
and updates in production.
Now how will you see this cost?
Well, we'll talk about
that in a moment.
But this brings
our second tip, one
that I think will resonate
well with users of GCP.
Use projects to
isolate and enforce
boundaries between
resources and use them
as containers for policy.
So they enforce
IAM permissions--
access and management
permissions--
of who can access resources and
other policies to dictate what
happens in a particular subset
of your resources on GCP.
So you should create
projects freely.
Lots of customers in GCP
start with one project
and go all the way
up to thousands.
You can think of them as
almost a free construct.
So how do these charges appear?
Well, you'll get a bill,
something like this
every month, an invoice.
And it tells you, of course,
how much is due up at the top.
It also tells you, on
a per project basis,
the usage of each service.
Now, a couple of
notes on this invoice.
First, the invoice is
always at the project level.
It is not going to
cut down and slice up
your cost into finer buckets.
Second is that once
you hit 25 pages,
this beautiful PDF turns
back into a one page PDF
and says the number you owe.
Some of our customers would
have literally thousands
and thousands of
pages of invoice,
and there's only
so much we're going
to generate into PDF form.
But behind every
PDF is also a CSV
that shows this level of
detail for as many rows of data
as you have.
Cost reporting is the second way
you can surface this cost data.
And there's a session that
goes much deeper into this.
But cost reporting is the
place to slice and dice
usage by time, by project,
by product, by SKU.
You can slice and dice just
about any way you can imagine.
And we're investing
a lot of resource
into making this a fast, first
class way of understanding
what's happening in GCP.
We'll come to a tip
in a moment, but this
is the place to
look for why cost
is happening and from where.
Now, if you want to
go a level deeper,
let's get into that
BigQuery export.
What do you get?
You get incredibly fine
grained usage, down to the SKU
and label level of
everything that's
happening across your projects.
And we'll talk, when we look
at the features of labels,
about how you can actually
use this to query your data.
And of course, there's
a separate section
that goes deep into it.
But the BigQuery export
is a fantastic tool
for understanding
every nuance of cost.
Critically, when you turn
on your BigQuery export
and have a question
down the road,
you can grant access
to your export
to Cloud Billing Support.
We have a dedicated team--
a support team that can help
you answer gnarly questions,
and they can do it
alongside you in data that's
available to both you and them.
So our tip around cost
reporting and invoicing.
The invoice tells
you what you owe.
Cost reporting tells
you why and where.
And we believe it's
important to keep
those two concepts separate.
So we've isolated our
resources into projects
as the basic organizing
entity in GCP.
We've looked at some of the
cost management tools and ways
that cost has surfaced
across the platform.
And the use cases are, of
course, much more broad
than what I described here.
With the production
environment and the development
environment, you can cut your
projects any way you like,
depending on how you
structure your resources.
And we'll look at some
more ways in a moment.
So our company is
growing like gangbusters.
We have projects galore.
We have added a staging
environment in the middle--
also a great idea.
We have an old macro-service.
I made that up.
It's not a micro-service.
It's a monolith that we
forklift into a project.
We have a TopSecret project.
We're not sure what the
new business development
team is doing, but they're
doing something in there--
very locked down, very secret.
Don't mention it.
And an archive project where
we put old storage data
in Cloud Storage.
Now, you can imagine, as
you go from one to two
to six to 10 projects to
100 that at some point,
this becomes a
little bit painful.
You might want to
control who has access
to these at the
highest level, who
is a member of your
organization, what policies do
you want to flow down across
all of these projects.
You might want to have detailed
audit logs of everything that's
happening inside
this organization.
And so we add a
centralization above projects
called a GCP organization.
And many of you--
I think almost half the
room raised their hand
when we asked how many of
you had a GCP organization.
Now, I'm going to get rid
of those dotted green lines
because something we're
working on hard today
is to add the concept of
a default billing account
at the organization level.
So in the future, you
won't have to think
about associating each project
to a separate billing account.
So going forward, I'm just
going to leave that one little
dotted green line and
one little blue line
to say that this organization
owns all of the projects
below it and the billing account
pays for all of the projects
below.
Now historically,
a GCP organization
required you to have a
G Suite Apps account.
It no longer does.
You can use a free
Cloud Identity account,
associate that to your
projects in Cloud,
and use organizations for free
without having to use G Suite.
So organizations are
available to everyone,
and they're a fantastic way
to control users, policies,
permissions at the top level.
And it's really easy to move
projects into an organization.
You can also move billing
accounts into an organization
yourself.
So we've gotten to
about 10 projects.
And already, I think you
can see that groupings
of these projects are
starting to divide themselves.
We have, on the left, our
development environments,
production, staging.
We have, in the middle,
our macro service.
It had some
environments, as well.
We've acquired two
companies, apparently.
Things are really moving.
TopSecret is still hiding on
the side, along with Archive.
Folders let you group
projects together.
Folders can be nested.
And they also let you
apply, in a more narrow way,
those policies and settings
that you previously applied
at the organization level.
And they are a
fantastic way to start
thinking about something
like a primary key for how
you organize billing data.
Now, a project can only
belong to one folder,
but of course it can belong
to a nested set of folders.
So you have to
think a little bit
ahead of how your folder
structure might represent
your resources and
your organization.
Here, we'll chop it
up one way, which
is to make an app section
for our main application,
put the macro-services and
their environments in a folder,
give BizDev their
acquired companies,
and leave TopSecret and
Archive off to the side.
And of course, you can go
much further than this.
You might choose to
cut by department.
If Finance wants to keep
an area for invoicing
and a storage area
for vendors, they
may do that in a
separate folder.
Of course, you can nest folders.
Sales has just gone and nested
their folders by region.
So folders mirror how you work.
And you'll see them start to
percolate throughout our cost
management tooling and
throughout our billing
infrastructure to give you that
view of groups of projects.
Now, let's get to
the most, I think,
powerful and interesting
feature of how to control cost,
and that is the label.
So you're living in this world.
You're a CFO.
And you say, wow, we have
a lot of resources in GCP.
I heard from a developer
the other day--
I was having lunch with them.
And they said that we're
spending 50% of our GCP dollars
on databases.
And I said, really?
I don't see database
up there anywhere.
How do I know what that
cost is across everything
that I operate?
So let's take just a
slice of this world.
We're going to take
the app section
and cut away the
rest for simplicity.
And let's show what's
under the hood.
We've brought services back.
We have GCE.
We have Cloud Storage.
We have BigQuery.
We have Cloud SQL.
And we have a bare
metal database
running on a bunch of
VMs inside our GCE bucket
here of resources.
So we can apply a label
to those resources.
Now, labels expose themselves
in different ways from service
to service.
And their function is not
only for purposes of billing.
Labels are used for other
reasons, such as in GCE,
you can filter and sort
and manage VMs by label.
Now, we've tagged our
bare metal databases here
with the type database.
And of course, Cloud SQL, we'll
want to tag those as databases,
as well.
But ha ha!
We realized that we only really
run databases-- a BigQuery
database in production.
We don't have that in
the other environments.
And we back up a whole
huge pile of database data
into Cloud Storage.
So let's label that
bucket Database
as well because it follows
the same cost model.
Now we have a
cross-cutting view of usage
that spans all of those
folders and projects,
and goes across our
entire organization.
Now, there are trade-offs
between folders and labels.
And as I mentioned, one
way to think about folders
is they're kind of a
primary key, a primary index
across your projects.
And projects can only
have one parent folder,
but resources and projects
can have many, many labels.
As I showed before, it's
common for customers
to have dozens of labels
on complex resources
that tell them all about
the environment, location,
customer type, and other
metadata about their resources.
Now our guidance here
is be deliberate.
Now, you have to be
especially deliberate
when you're constructing
folders because you
have to build a hierarchy.
But with labels,
it's a good idea
to be deliberate, as well--
define the keys that are
mandatory across services,
define what valid values are,
and set a policy around which
kinds of services require
labeling and which don't.
And as I mentioned,
some services
use labels for other functions.
Some services also
apply their own labels
to resources for
your benefit when
you're looking at BigQuery
export in other places.
So you'll get cluster IDs.
Deployment Manager will
append IDs onto its resources.
And you'll see those
percolate all the way
throughout cost reporting
and throughout BigQuery.
Now, how does this
actually look?
Here is a slice of
a BigQuery export.
If you had a pool of VMs
that are reporting cost
through to BigQuery, we
are going to cut those up
by labeled usage.
So you'll get a line item for
each combination of labels
and the associated cost.
And one of the great
powers of BigQuery
is its ability to query
into nested data structures.
So we provide you example
queries and example
ways of surfacing these
labels in our BigQuery export
documentation that tell you and
let you pivot on those values
to do real fine
cost attribution.
So use labels for
cross-cutting reporting
that span all of your projects.
And they're powerful.
We have customers who use
them as their primary means
of managing cost and don't
use folders as heavily.
It depends on your workload.
And it depends how flexibly you
want to see the world of cost.
I will caution you
on one note, which
is that most of our labels
are evaluated at the time
that BigQuery export runs.
So if you're applying labels
in a really high frequency way
to underlying
resources, your export
may not exactly match
those in perfect real time.
So when I say high frequency,
I mean if you're putting labels
on and off resources at an
inter-hour or a really fine
rate, much faster than
our BigQuery export,
which is a few
hours delayed, you
may see the last
value of that label.
So it's worth
experimenting with.
And if you have
needs that require
real fine grain labeling in
real time, come talk to us.
Reach out to the billing product
management or engineering
teams, and we'll be happy to
talk to you about those cases.
Now, a few advanced topics.
And I think we'll have about
10 minutes for questions
after we get through advanced
topics and our summary.
And we'll have two microphones
ready for you for any questions
you have.
So please start thinking
of them in your mind.
First, billing roles
and permissions.
Billing permissions are separate
from resource permissions.
What I mean by that is
you have a series of roles
that you can centrally
control if you
have an organization
on the billing
accounts in that organization.
Some of those common roles are
the billing administrator role,
who has the rights
to do everything,
a billing account creator,
who can create other billing
accounts, and a
billing account viewer,
who can look at
cost and reporting,
but who cannot
change the settings,
change the way
payments are processed,
change how your
finances are run.
Now, once your GCP
organization is established,
there are a couple
of best practices
around billing
account permissions
that we want you to
take home with you.
The first is, after
you've created your org,
if you're a preexisting GCP
customer, move your billing
accounts into the org.
That doesn't happen
for you automatically.
There's a big button on
top of the billing account
that says to choose
the organization it's
associated to.
So you can move them and gain
that same level of control
you have after you've
moved all of your projects
into the organization,
which is the second tip.
The third is once you have
your billing structure set up,
you can remove the
billing account creator
role that exists as a
default at the top level
of the organization.
It's there to allow the easy
adoption of organizations,
but once you've got your
structure nailed down,
you may well want
to take it away.
A couple of best practices
on billing account hygiene.
All things equal,
we generally think
that fewer billing accounts
are preferable to many,
unless you have specific
reasons for having
lots of billing accounts.
Costs always flow up to
a single billing account.
And you can think of
that billing account
as the top level container
for cost reporting.
So if you have usage spread
across billing accounts,
you may have to construct
reports in less easy ways
to see costs between
those billing accounts.
Some of the reasons
you may want or need
multiple billing accounts.
If you have divisions
of a large corporation,
they may want their
own control of costs.
They may operate in
their own currency.
As I mentioned before,
a billing account
operates in a single currency.
And there may be
other reasons that you
want to split charges or
split invoicing in a way that
follow a different path.
Above all, if you're thinking
you're going down that route,
talk to your account
manager or I'm
happy to answer questions after.
But generally speaking,
fewer is better.
Finally, you may have a
use case for charge-backs
internally inside
your organization,
where you have one
billing account,
but where you're
allocating costs
in a more discreet manner
inside your company.
And there are different
ways to cut charge-backs.
You can do it by folder.
You can do it by label.
You can do it by project.
We'd love to help with that
problem, so by all means,
please reach out and
talk to us, and we're
happy to give you some
idea of best practice
and give you an idea of
what other customers have
done before you with
our reporting tools.
Finally, a note-- I
mentioned it earlier.
There is a dedicated Cloud
Billing Support team.
Whether you pay for Google
Cloud Support or not,
this team is always available
to you to answer questions.
And in the support
section, there's
a clear link that says where to
reach out to the Cloud Billing
Support team.
And as I've hammered
home, they will
be extra excited if you turned
on your BigQuery billing export
because they'd love to
get down in and help you
with some of those cost
attribution questions
at the fine level of detail.
So a quick summary, some
ways to learn more, and then
about 10 minutes for questions.
First-- you've already
heard me say that enough--
turn it on.
Projects are a great way
to enforce boundaries,
and you can create them freely.
Use projects for any
use case you see fit.
Prefer cost reporting to relying
on the invoice for details
about cost.
The invoice is a great tool
for that quick summary,
but cost reporting lets you get
down to slicing and dicing cost
in all of the ways
we've talked about.
GCP Orgs are for everyone.
They're a fantastic way
to control resources
if you don't already
have one, and you
can set them up either
using Cloud IDaaS
or using your G Suite
applications domain.
Folders, which you can nest
up to four levels deep,
are a great way to mirror the
structure of how you work,
whether it's by team, by
department, by project,
with how your resources
sit in Google Cloud.
And you can think of them
something like the primary key
or the primary way to
index your projects.
And finally, labels are a way
to supercharge reporting and cut
across the boundaries
of projects.
Create as many as you like.
Use them for those cases where
you need to slice and dice
in ways that folders can't
do or folders can't do alone.
And as I said, Cloud Billing
Support is here to help.
We've heard from
lots of customers.
We talk to customers every day
about the different problems
they're aiming to
solve with billing.
And we're thrilled to help
and find solutions any time.
As I mentioned, there
are four more sessions--
IO 103-- Monitoring and
Forecasting your GCP Costs
on Thursday at 11:40 AM.
IO 128-- Saving Money
on Compute Engine,
talking about committed and
sustained use discounts.
IO 208 on Wednesday, which
dives into billing data
with BigQuery and Data Studio.
BigQuery is something
you can query
ad hoc in the style
of SQL, or you
can use Data Studio and
our other reporting tools
on top to give you
visualizations and really
rich custom cost reporting.
And finally, controlling costs
with financial governance,
which is at 3:15 today.
There's also a cost
management showcase
where you can see if you
can handle Black Friday.
I encourage you
to check that out.
I believe it's downstairs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]